hi there this is my first appearance at
the Academy Awards oddly I was not
nominated for my delicate betrayal of
the beloved and weight challenged
character Santa Claus so with that in
mind I thought I'd take this opportunity
on worldwide television to promote my
personal political causes sadly I have
no personal political causes Thank You
Victor good day I was a little depressed
about this morning but my mom called and
mom could cheer me up like nobody else
she goes Timmy
life is like a box of hand grenades you
touch anything and you're gonna die I'm
especially pleased to present the
category of live-action short films
because back in 1986 my short film won
an award at the American Film Institute
you all remember the last days of OJ
Lake probably not a short film sadly or
not seen enough which makes them even
more special to me the people make them
do it for the love of the craft and the
nominations for the best achievement in
live-action short films are French
Kafka's It's a Wonderful Life Peter
Capaldi and Ruth Kenley let's kangaroo
court Sean Austin and Christine Astin
on hope Jobeth Williams Michelle McGuire
syrup while Unwin and Nick Vivian Trevor
Peggy Rice key and Randy stone and the
Oscar goes to
it's a tie Oman yeah
Fred's cop gets wonderful life Peter
Capaldi Ruth Kenley let's and Trevor
Peggy rice key and Randy stone
- um well Trevor first came to life as a
stage piece conceived after our
wonderful writer James Lucine heard a
report on NPR about teen suicide and
learned that approximately one-third of
all teens who kill themselves are gay we
made our film for anyone who's ever made
felt like an outsider it celebrates all
those who make it through difficult
times and mourns those who didn't in
honoring us the Academy honors everyone
who so generously supported our project
our thanks to them and my husband Josh
who helps make all things pass this
project was a perfect experience for us
from the beginning it seemed to be
blessed everybody we asked the help said
yes
Peggy James myself wanted to send a
message our cast crew and contributors
made it possible we want to thank our
family and friends Allen Landsberg Peter
Roth Charlie goldstein especially Jodie
whose love support and encouragement
inspires and helped us achieve our best
we love you thank you
this is very very thrilling for us I'd
like to take this opportunity to thank
the Academy and I'd also like to very
much thank the Scottish film production
fund and BBC Scotland who backed our
film was so much goodwill and generosity
I'd also like to thank my husband
Crispin let's who makes everything
possible for me and I'm now going to
pass you over to Peter ok thanks
I've got 19 seconds of a short speech
I'd like to thank everybody who worked
on the film give them the gift of
themselves a huge amount of her talent
generosity Richard E Grant who was
fabulous Ruth Kenley let I was a
fabulous producer and Elaine Collins who
was the real creative dynamo behind it
all I'm a my mum and dad and the Academy
thanks a lot bye
good evening ladies and yeah what a
party haha what a swery
that's rich ah you gotta love these
Shriners conventions what a Lollapalooza
what uh hmm that's funny
well I'll be Jodie Foster Oh Sharon boom
boy what a flash drive is Shrine
Auditorium Academy Award
the nominees for the best achievement in
animated short films are the big story
Tim Watts and David Scott
Bob's boyfriend
Allyson Snowden and David fine the
janitor
Vanessa Schwartz the monk in the fish
Michael do doc give it triangle Erika
Russell and the Oscar goes to hurry up
hurry up
Bob's birthday Allison Snowden and David
fine congratulations
you
I think I'm gonna stand here and watch
the clock countdown that'll be easier
thank you to the Academy we'd also like
to thank Channel 4 television in Britain
and Claire kits in particular for
commissioning the film and for
supporting British animation so much
over the years we'd also like to thank
the National Film Board of Canada Barry
MacLean and David barrel for
co-producing with us also thanks to Andy
Hamilton Harry Enfield Janet Pearlman
Patrick Godfrey and everyone who worked
so hard on the film over two years known
our friends and family for all the
inspiration and support and most
importantly we'd like to dedicate this
award to the memory of our dear friend
Mike Gribble who sadly isn't here
tonight thank you very very much Susan
Sarandon Tim Robbins and especial for
not
nominated songs from The Lion King next
on Oscar night